Just in.
Japanese authorities
now checking on the status of their moon
sniper, robotic explorer,
as it did
touch down on the lunar surface
in the last hour.
They'll provide updates just in a bit.
Let's get to CNN's Christine Fisher.
It appears the moon sniper did land,
but not in the Sea of Tranquility
somewhere else.
Correct?
It's called the Sea of nectar.
Sara And what we know
is that this spacecraft called Slim,
which is short for the Smart Lander
for investigating the moon.
It has touched down
on the surface of the moon.
But the big question is,
what kind of condition is it in?
The spacecraft is communicating
with the ground specifically.
Japan's space agency, or JAXA.
But did the spacecraft perhaps
tip over rollover or worst case scenario,
did it completely crash
into the surface of the moon?
We just don't know yet.
And we're awaiting
a press conference
from JAXA, the Japanese space agency
Any minute now we're hopefully
we will get some answers.
And so it's really too soon to say,
excuse me
if this was a success or a failure,
because you know what
What is a success
if you land on the moon,
that is a pretty big feat
in and of itself.
But then if you tip over
and you can't perform
some of the scientific observations
that you were hoping for it to perform.
Does that still constitute a success?
So a lot of questions here.
But Sarah, if successful,
this will be such a huge deal for Japan.
And it space agency
because it will become
only the fifth country
in the history of the world
to land on
the surface of the moon successfully
and only the third country
this century,
only China and India have done it.
It's been more than 50 years
since the U.S.
has done
it, which was back in 1972
at the end of the Apollo program.
So really a momentous moment
for Japan Space Agency.
Everybody is really holding their breath,
waiting to see what is going to happen.
And, you know, in addition
to these historic firsts, potentially
this rover called that the moon sniper
is demonstrating this really cool
pinpoint technology
trying to land in an area
just the size of a football field.
You compare that to previous landers.
Their target
landing site was several kilometers
or even miles long.
So if successful,
not just a historic first for Japan,
but also a really impressive
step forward
in terms of the types of technology
for these kinds of lunar landers.
I'm just being told
there was a press conference
from the Japan
Aerospace Exploration Agency
about the spacecraft on the moon.
Let's listen in. 1020.
They just
smiled, land out for investigate moon
and landed on the moon
and we
have been able to confirm
that it has arrived on the moon
surface to be sure.
My name is Colleen aka the the director
general of ISIS, as I was explained.
But each of
smart land up
for investigating Moon Slim, so
we made a challenge to it.
Landing on the moon.
No, the Slim has been
communicating to
the earth has our station
and it is receiving command
from the Earth accurately and is is
the spacecraft is responding to these
in a normal way.
However,
it seems that
the solar cell
is not generating electricity
at this point in time.
And since we are not
able to generate electricity
and so the operation is being done
using batteries on low.
So and
that based on the data
and landing
has been stored on the safe spacecraft.
And so we are trying to
data source that are to the earth
and we are making an effort to maximize
the scientific achievement.
And during the descent to the moon,
all due to that.
And while hovering above the
the moon surface,
we have been able to
separate our live one and let one.
And once
I separated, I will automatically send
the right signal.
And that has been successful.
So we do consider
live one
and have to have been
successfully separated.
And we are making an effort to acquire
data at this point in time.
And in order for us to analyze the data,
we will require some time
That has been the case
schedule from the the start.
And so in regards to sharing of the data,
we will require a little more time.
And so what we know at this point in time
is, as I have explained,
and so we are still gathering data
to understand
the situation of this spacecraft also.
So you got Slim has a target.
Did
the high precision landing
with an accuracy of 100 meters?
Well, we require to do a detailed
analysis of data as we have
indicated in advance.
And so as to
whether we have been able to achieve
100 meter accuracy or known,
we would require a little more time
for us to be able
to confirm on this point.
And also and
so we will gather that data.
We have been able to gather
and we are hoping of holding
a press conference next week
as well at a precise date.
We will inform you
next week.
And so that is what we know
at this point in time.
So what is the answer to that?
Thank you very much.
Any followup comment from Dr.
Sugimoto?
Thank you. Thank you very much.
The materials have been distributed
to everybody in the venue
and also those who participated
through WebEx online.
And we are also maybe streaming
this programs.
So if you haven't received the materials
yet, please wait for them.
And also there will be a press release
on the website of JAXA.
And we're updating information
every now and then on the website.
So please
be patient to receive the materials.
Thank you very much indeed.
From another one other issue,
I would like to start taking questions
from the members of the press.
So we have members
joining in the venue
as well as online participants.
So first participants in the venue,
followed by questions
by online participants.
If you are participating
through the line,
please state your name and affiliation
by typing, not into the chat.
And then we will appoint you.
So from the venue
please wait for the microphone.
Once you get the microphone,
please state your name and affiliation
before you ask your question.
And since there are many members
of the media
joining this session,
so please
limit your question
to just one question and be brief.
No. All right.
You've just been listening
to a live press conference out of Japan
with Japan
essentially confirming that
the lunar spacecraft,
the lunar spacecraft, is now on the moon.
They had been
checking its status earlier.
They weren't necessarily sure,
but they have confirmed
that the lunar spacecraft
is on the moon
and landed at around 12:20 a.m.
Saturday local time.
They said that it is receiving command
from the earth.
Unfortunately, though, they did mention
the solar cell
is not generating electricity,
that it is using batteries.
And as a result,
because this has been successful,
Japan is now
officially the fifth country ever
to accomplish this.